the Joe Rogan experience do you think
that people will put up with that though
I mean America breaks breaks up as it
doesn't become the the Pro Open and Pro
close dates and then we just divorce
well this is what's happening yeah it's
right it's right wing left wing left
wing people want the government take
care of anything everything they want
everybody to get checks and they want
everybody to stay home forever until
there's a cure who's not gonna be a cure
this is something that's going to be
around and we might have heard immunity
you might be able to wipe it out that
way right this is not something that
they can just spray away or inject away
right so this is something well
hopefully one day they'll have some sort
of real treatment whether it's vaccine
or whatever it is we're probably gonna
have to take a vaccine every couple
years or every year yeah it's not none
of this is good I mean you take the you
get the flu shot if you get it and it's
not gonna keep you from getting the flu
but there's no other strains that are
out there but it helps you even though
you get no strains that aren't the
strains exactly
then there's herd immunity right we're
more than 60% of the people get it the
virus or dies off that's that's a that's
a positive possibility in the future but
you repeat there's people that are
wanting to want to get back to work and
there's people that don't want anyone to
go anywhere and those and it's become
this sort of again this ideological
battleground where the people that want
to go back to work you're putting
dollars over money you know like one of
someone said you're gonna be the richest
man the cemetery to Elon Musk's he wants
to open up his factory like what what
are you talking about like are we gonna
be just stay home forever we're gonna be
scared of everything why would you drive
when you know how many people died in
driving is stay home don't do anything
and I think this has put you know the we
make these calculations all the time
about how many people is it acceptable
to die it's just not so in our face for
instance with opioids or the opiate if
you're using these to help people manage
pain but you know a certain amount of
people might become addicted or die
there's all kinds of trade-offs that
we're making driving another
good example so we're constantly making
these cost-benefit analysis in our
society it's just not usually you have
to make it you know it's like you have
to be part of the person who's saying am
I going to be but it's it's also there's
so much false information or confusing
information and I don't again I come
back to what we started talking about I
don't know that a lot of people know who
to believe and if you just believe your
tribe it's much easier I think if I was
just like gobbling up all the CNN or
gobbling up all the Fox I would be happy
little freaking no nihilism Bridgette
or you'd be angry wanting to overthrow
the government not one to you know be
terrified and not leaving my house
because I was worried that I was gonna
get there's all those all those things
but if you just look at the raw numbers
and this doesn't discount any of the
deaths doesn't discount the tragedy I
know people are but my grandma but my
friend I know a guy I know a guy he was
young everybody knows a guy you're right
but if you just look at the overall
numbers this is not what we thought it
was going to be it's really simple and
this is why you want to move yeah I
don't like that they're telling me that
you have to stay home yeah I don't like
they're telling me you have to wear a
mask when you go outside no if I'm
around people you want me to wear a mask
in a business or something it's not ok
yeah I'm fine with that
until everything settles down we figure
this out okay you can't tell me I leave
the house I have to put a mask on what
about if I walk around my backyard do I
have to have a mask on what does that
mean I mean yes I'm running on a trail I
have to run on a trail with a mask on
the [ __ ] out of here
and you mean your ideal way to
transition back what would it be what
would it look like people take risks
yeah let people do what they want to do
but educate them educate them in terms
of their immune system educate them in
terms of like here's where it could go
bad this is why you need to wash your
hands like one of the things I said is
that women we're getting it less than
men people like why I'm like because
we're gross we don't wash we're [ __ ]
disgusting so guys are picking their
nose after they're touching a faucet and
other people touched it and
is that why they're getting it more it
could be a bunch of factors guaranteed
it one of them is that men are gross yes
men are gross yeah I guarantee that has
to play some sort of a part in it yeah
yeah I mean it's it's been somebody I
think I'm a writer I forget her name
Megan someone she had a tweet she said
it's a black it's a black light no it's
a yeah it's a black light on like the
sperm filled hotel room basically the
pandemic it just reveals like these
institutional failures and all just
structural failures and all of the
ideological battleground is even up to
11 now and I
I find that most people are wrestling
and don't know really what to do but I
think most people are grown-up enough to
want to be able to take that risk for
themselves I walk around I see all these
businesses I'm like how are these
businesses gonna come back they're not
going to we're gonna lose like 40% of
them look I think we you got to let
people make their own decisions and the
decision you've already made has already
cost something its cost businesses its
cost a lot its cost a lot of people's
livelihoods so it's not like there's no
loss here there's a loss here and if you
don't think there's a loss of life talk
to people that are that are dealing with
suicide talk I know a guy who talked to
this sheriff and who's saying that I do
everyone does
everyone they were saying that he used
to deal with one suicide a week now he's
dealing with five a day Wow yeah yes
holy [ __ ] yeah it seems like it should
be a bigger story but it is a big story
but it's just not being talked about
because the the narrative is always stay
or safer stay at home this night and
this is crazy
we went there's a lot there's a real
loss yeah it comes with your business
going away oh yeah it's not just loss of
life its loss of business loss of
livelihood and that could lead to loss
of life yeah
and it's going to last for years it was
creepy I was texting me the pictures of
the phosphorescence you know it was it's
amazing and every what are you gonna
tell people they can't go look at nature
and so I think it was Cinco de Mayo we
down and everybody was out like so many
people there are no cops I couldn't
believe it it was I was like yeah just
gonna do yeah so tell people get off the
beach yeah that's so so that night
everyone's wearing masks everyone's
responsible socially distancing it was
fine it was really cool it was chill you
could tell everyone was going crazy
stir-crazy
people were partying because it was
Cinco DeMayo is awesome I'm like yeah
good job California I went down the next
day and it appears the word I got out
and they had turned the ferris wheel
down at the pier into like a weird
creepy dystopian message it was just
like hey support are certain are health
care workers and then there was a red
cross in the ferris wheel and the police
were there and they were like everyone
off the boot the beaches are closed we
will cite you and no to the people's
credit no one gave a [ __ ] and didn't
move but they were driving up and now
and telling everybody but it was a
creepy vibe with the like ferris wheel
and the messaging that had totally
changed overnight well go to the
hospitals out here they're empty yeah
yeah it's a real problem hospitals are
going bankrupt I know I know and and
there's I read a thing about how college
might go bankrupt too so I don't know
how the schools are gonna allow private
schools that are charging exorbitant
rates and expect people to do that [ __ ]
in front of a computer they're gonna go
under yeah they're gonna go under but I
mean again you at least have a platform
you can talk about this and and an
audience that you hear from and what
what's the general area yeah there's a
certain percentage of people that are
cowards and they just want to trust in
the government and let the government
make these decisions they're doing this
with sound science and no but they're
not but they're not if they were I'd be
like okay I get it cuz I was like okay I
get it in the beginning I didn't protest
it in the beginning I canceled gigs I
backed off I said I think they're trying
to save us but then when you get the
science in when you get the actual
numbers in you're like no this is way
different than they thought you didn't
thought it was gonna be hundreds of
thousands dead in California alone no so
thousand people eighteen hundred people
whatever it is do you think it'll be
worse than average age of people die
this is older than the average age yeah
it's like 85 plus the average age people
die of this is older than the average
age people die yeah like what
[Applause]